okay so this video we are going to
discuss neurons and impulses or action
potentials so let's get started well if
we're gonna talk about neurons let's
just do a very brief overview on the
nervous system like any body system the
cells the most basic unit of life and
cells are arranged into tissues and
tissues are arranged in organs and
organs and the organ system known as the
nervous system but this particular
system is really crucial to controlling
our thoughts the way we move and a lot
of the life processes that we depend
upon not only that but our nervous
system is quick now you can imagine in
this case we can see that this person
the eye is being exposed to bright light
look how small the black opening the
pupil is but in a blink of an eye in a
very short amount of time if you were to
dim the lights in the room the pupil
would relax and open up and this would
allow the little light that's in the
room to enter the eye but this happens
almost instantly but a lot of
information has to be passed to and from
the brain in order for this to happen
we're going to kind of learn how the
cells do this
so let's start talking about neurons
this is the basic unit of of the nervous
system these are the nerve cells you can
see from the picture
they have these weird shapes to them
they almost look like trees with
branches and roots to them well their
function is to transfer electrical
signals or what we call impulses to and
from the brain we're gonna kind of break
a neuron down into three main parts
number one being the cell body and this
is the part of the cell that contains a
lot of the organelles you're probably
familiar with the nucleus mitochondria
Golgi bodies you name it notice coming
off of the cell body there are lots and
lots and lots of small branches we call
these dendrites you'll see what I mean
in a moment by that by the definition it
says they receive impulses from
neighboring cells you'll see what I mean
in a moment by that notice how there's a
long stretch a long single straightaway
stretch that's called the axon and it
will carry an impulse it'll carry this
electrical signal away from the cell
body again you'll see what I mean by
that you know I also want to label the
tip of the axon what's called the axon
terminal that's a very important part
and you'll see much later in this video
why that's important but I do want to
bring that up just to get you used to
seeing it well look at the top of the
screen so here comes a an impulse I'm
just using this yellow spiky shaped
object to represent an electrical
impulse well notice how there's the cell
in the middle watch what happens the
cell in the middle will create its own
impulse that impulse was created by a
dendrite like it says dendrites will
receive impulses from their neighbors so
the dendrite just received this impulse
from the cell above it and now the
impulse will travel down the length of
the axon and it reaches the axon
terminal what happens next well the very
bottom cell the dendrites on the very
bottom cell will receive this
pulse and travel down its self we're
gonna learn how neurons do this as we go
through this video let's first talk
about the basic types of neurons there
are the sensory neurons and like the
name implies these are related to our
senses they detect stimuli and they
transmit signals to and from the brain
in this woman's hand there are sensory
neurons you know related to our sense of
touch and everything and so let's say
she's reaching over an open flame and
the heat activates these sensory neurons
well a signal will be sent from nerve to
nerve to nerve to nerve to nerve up the
arm up the spine and into the brain so
these sensory neurons detect our senses
so we have sensory neurons in our eyes
to detect light and that's our site we
have sensory neurons in our nose to
smell various molecules we have sensory
no neurons in our ears to detect
pressure we have sensory neurons on our
tongue to detect taste and we have
sensory neurons all over our skin to
detect the various touches well then
there's the inter neurons let's come
back to our our woman here and these are
these inter neurons are located within
the brain so here she is again touching
the heat and the sensory neurons that we
just mentioned in our hand are gonna
send a signal to the brain
well that signals going to the brain
that signals go into the inter neurons
in the brain the neurons are gonna
process this information so notice that
the inter neurons are receiving the
signals from the sensory neurons well
then there are the motor neurons and
what these do is they're gonna pass
signals to other tissue so here she is
touching the hot flame a signal goes up
her arm into her brain and then the
brain will send a signal back to the
muscles in our in her hand
well let's zoom on in when we zoom on in
here we see a motor neuron
connected to various muscles in her hand
and when the signal gets to the muscles
it will cause those muscles to stretch
and contract now what is the stretching
and contracting end up causing the woman
to do it causes her to jump away from
the flame so she doesn't burn herself
too badly so I hope you saw what I mean
by that the motor neurons will pass
signals to other tissues in that example
the motor neurons were passing signals
to muscles and they reacted by
stretching and contracting so let's get
into how these neurons work let's talk
about their resting potential this is
one of neurons at rest you know right
now I don't have any food in my mouth I
don't have a mint in my mouth so the
taste buds the taste cells on my tongue
are at their resting state their resting
potential they are not sending taste
signals to my brain right now let's zoom
on in to this cell membrane of this
neuron here for a closer look okay so
you can see the top of the cell membrane
is the outside of the cell on the bottom
is the inside well we can actually
insert a little tiny micro electrode
into a nacelle to record its internal
charge and inside of this cell turns out
there's a negative charge because
floating around in the cytoplasm are a
bunch of proteins and and these proteins
tend to have a negative charge to them
now is every molecule in the cell
negatively charged no turns out the cell
is also packed with a lot of positively
charged potassium ions and those are
gonna be super important in a little bit
now despite the positively charged
potassium ions the internal charge is
still around it negative 70 millivolts
that's because of all the negatively
charged proteins well when we do the
same thing to the outside of the cell
the exterior turns out the exterior
registers a
positive charge because outside of the
cell are a bunch of bunch of bunch of
sodium na is the symbol for sodium
sodium ions and they have a positive
charge and so what we're going to see is
how the sodium's and the potassium
interact as the neuron goes through its
action
so let's talk about how the neuron does
its action or what's called an action
potential an action potential also known
as an impulse you know the analogy I
like to make is if you've ever gone to a
sporting event where the whole crowd is
doing the wave and you're just kind of
watching the wave go around the stadium
it's kind of fun one person stands and
sits then the next person stands and
sits in a moment I hope you'll see why I
chose this as an analogy to an action
potential well I'm gonna put this chart
up here you're gonna see this chart a
lot but it'd be a good idea to add this
to your notes but you'll see and we're
gonna talk about this the scale here as
we go through the video so let's get
into how an action potential works like
we said earlier sodium is on the outside
of the cell and potassium Zhan the
inside now the inside of the cell has a
negative 70 millivolts arge because of
all the negatively charged proteins now
for simplicity I didn't draw the
proteins in my picture because they
would just Bend too much clutter but
pretend that they are they're given the
inside of the cell a charge of negative
70 millivolts and so what an action
potentials the definition is it's an
impulse it's triggered and it moves down
the length of an axon and so let's talk
about how the impulse is generated well
notice how the internal charge changed
to negative 40 millivolts now you'll see
what caused that in a moment right now
that's really not the concern but at
negative 40 millivolts what's gonna
happen is that black doorway that black
sodium channel in the cell membrane is
going to open and once that happens
sodium is going to diffuse from a high
concentration to a low concentration
basically from the outside of the inside
and sodium is gonna begin to accumulate
on the inside what's that gonna do to
the charge on the inside the negative 40
millivolt charge is gonna go
up- thirty negative 20 negative 10 0 10
20 30 40 50 and around positive 50
millivolts is when that black sodium
door is gonna close well something else
happens let's talk about what happens at
the at the back end of this impulse
around positive 50 millivolts there's
those red potassium channels that just
opened these potassium channels respond
to the internal charge when the internal
charge has reached the plus 50 they
spring open and I hope you see what's
gonna happen next the K pluses the
potassium Tsar gonna diffuse from the
high to a low concentration out of the
cell and they begin to accumulate
outside the cell what's that gonna do to
the internal charge the internal charge
is currently positive 50 but as the
potassium exits the charge is gonna drop
back into the negative range again it
actually drops all the way back down to
negative 90 millivolts and we'll talk
about this in more detail in a moment
and around negative 90 millivolts those
red potassium doors close and then this
whole process just repeats over and over
and over and I hope to show you what I
mean by that in a moment
well here we have two neurons in close
proximity that yellow spiky object
there's our impulse our action potential
and it's moving down the neuron it's
down the axon let's freeze right there
you know what let's go ahead and zoom on
in for a closer look and when we zoom on
in for a closer look we see the cell
interior in gray and the exterior is the
white area well let me add that there is
sodium on the outside of the neuron and
potassium on the inside of the neuron
and here's our scale that I referenced
earlier we're gonna use this a lot now
the resting potential in a neuron is
around negative 70 millivolts well let's
say we're responding to touch the
physical force at the surface of the
cell will actually deform that first
black sodium door and cause it to open
so just the pressure from touch will
cause that black sodium door to open
once that happens I hope you can see
what's gonna happen the sodium is going
to diffuse into the neuron and the chain
the charge is going to change with all
of these positive sodium's coming in the
charge is gonna go up from negative 70
negative 60 negative 50 negative 40
negative 30 negative 20 negative 10 0 10
20 30 40 50 and around positive 50 look
on the chart of the scale the black
sodium door is gonna close not only that
but the red potassium door is open or
once they open I hope you can see what's
gonna happen next
a lot of the potassium will start to
diffuse out what's that going to do to
the charge the positive 50 charge is
gonna drop because the cell is losing a
bunch of positive potassium the charge
goes from plus 52 plus 40 plus 30 plus
20 plus 10 zero negative 10 negative 20
negative 30 negative 40 and something
happens interesting around negative 40
watch what happens around negative 40
the next black sodium door is gonna open
and sodium is gonna start to diffuse on
in now even though sodium is diffusing
in watched the charge it's still gonna
drop down to negative 90 I hope you see
why that is there's just more potassium
doors open because there's more
potassium channels open potassium is
gonna exit in greater amounts and the
charge is gonna keep dropping well once
we get to negative 90 look on the scale
those are opened red potassium doors are
gonna close well now the sodium is the
only thing that's entering the cell and
it's beginning to accumulate what's that
gonna do the charge the charge is gonna
start to go up because all of the sodium
is now accumulating it's gonna go up
from negative 90 to negative 18 negative
70 negative 60 up up up up up all the
way to plus 50 look on the scale what
happens at plus 50 the black sodium door
closes and the next sets of red
potassium doors and channels open well
once those potassium channels open the
potassium will start to diffuse outward
and it starts to accumulate outside of
the neuron the charge drops the charge
begins to drop again from plus 50 all
the way down and around negative 40 the
next sodium door opens and even though
sodium is diffusing in because there's
more potassium diffusing out the charge
continues to fall all the way to
negative 90 at negative 90 the red
potassium doors closed and the sodium is
still entering and so it's starting to
accumulate that's gonna cause the charge
to go from negative 90 all the way back
up to positive 50 look on the on the the
scale in the upper right hand corner at
plus 50 that black sodium doorway
channel will close the next set of red
potassium channels were open and we're
just repeating ourselves the potassium
begins to exit and the charge plummet
well here's a little simpler animation
that again I hope you see why I chose
people doing the wave at a ball game as
a good analogy to an impulse the person
doing the wave stands up and sits down
the next person stands up and sits down
that's kind of like every time sodium
comes in the charge goes positive and
then when potassium exits it goes back
to Nora
to negative so the charge jumping up the
plus 50 negative 90 plus 50 negative 90
standing sitting standing sitting plus
50 negative 90 I hope you see why I
chose the analogy of people doing the
wave at a ball game
well now that the impulse has passed I
hope you see we've kind of got a problem
the natural state of the cell is now out
of balance
remember potassium is normally on the
inside of the cell but a lot of it's now
accumulated on the outside and sodium is
normally on the outside of a cell but a
lot of it has accumulated on the inside
there has to be something to clean up
this mess and reset the cell to normal
the cleaning up the mess the who who
cleans up the mess it's called the
sodium potassium pump in the cell
membrane there's another there's a there
are other objects I didn't add them
until right now
there they are in blue the sodium
potassium pumps they've always been
there pretend but I've been holding them
until now to talk about well how do they
clean up the mess they use ATP in active
transport to pump molecules from a lower
to a higher area of concentration and so
what is gonna happen during this cleanup
process sodium is going to be pumped
back out of the cell the cell then the
sodium potassium pump can actually hold
one to three sodium's at a time and with
the help of ATP an enzyme will break ATP
and release heat that heat will cause
the sodium potassium pump to change its
configuration to allow the sodium to be
pumped out not only does it pump sodium
out but it also will pump a couple 1-2
potassium back into the cell as the heat
wears away the protein returns to its
normal shape the sodium potassium pump
returns to its normal shape and the
potassium is pumped in let's repeat that
again three sodium's at a time loading
the sodium potassium pump a molecule of
ATP is broken the heat causes that
causes the sodium potassium pump to
change its shape to release the sodium
then to potassium enter into the sodium
potassium pump and it returns to its
normal shape to bring the
seems in so when does this cleanup
happen what happens at after the impulse
is passed where is the sodium potassium
pump located it's in the cell membrane
but most importantly why is it important
it restores the initial charge inside
and outside of the cell let's do that
one more time three put three sodium's
enter into the sodium potassium pump ATP
is broken heat is released it causes the
sodium potassium pump to change its
shape release in the sodium to potassium
enter in the sodium potassium pump
returns to its normal shape the
potassium is brought in you can imagine
if all of these are pumping sodium out
and potassium in in a very short amount
of time
boom they can reset the cell to their
north to its normal negative 70
millivolts resting state and now the
cell is able to neuron is able to send
another impulse should it be required to
do so
that's really the importance of the
sodium potassium pump
well here we are again at our two
neighboring neurons again here's the
axon here's the axons terminal and
here's the dendrite of the neighboring
neuron well let's continue the impulse
down the axon and eventually the impulse
arrives at the axons terminal
we gotta zoom in here and take a closer
look when we zoom in we come to what's
called the synapse well here's the axon
terminal on the left here's the dendrite
on the right notice there's a little gap
in between the two that gap is called
the synapse it's the gap between neurons
let's talk about what happens here the
steps that happen here well the impulse
will reach the axons terminal so here we
have a sodium channel opening sodium
rushes in and the charge jumps up to
plus 50 we just got done talking about
that but now the impulse has reached the
end of the axon the axon is terminal
notice how there are vesicles in the
axons terminal with three little black
dots in them we'll talk about those
black dots in a moment the vesicles are
little storage organelles and notice
what's gonna happen here this vesicle is
about to fuse with the cell membrane and
when it does it's gonna release those
black dots those black dots are
beginning to be released into the
synapse those black dots are what are
called neurotransmitter proteins
neurotransmitters are released from that
vesicle and they will diffuse across the
synapse and they land on what's called
the dendrite receptor a little landing
zone that the dendrites have to catch
these neurotransmitter proteins here and
now that the dendrite receptor has
caught the neurotransmitters watch what
happens it will open its its own sodium
channel and then sodium rushes in like
we talked about a moment ago the charge
jumps up to plus 50 when that happens
black sodium door closes the red
potassium door is open and the potassium
begins to exit when that happens the
charge falls all the way down the
negative 90 millivolts we just got done
talking about this notice what's
happened that the neuron on the right
created a brand new impulse and here we
have five neurons let's pretend that you
want to move the muscles in your foot
and so what happens is sound number one
will make an impulse the impulse travels
down cell 1 cell 1 releases
neurotransmitters the neurotransmitters
are caught by cell to cell 2 makes its
own impulse the impulse travels down
cell to cell 2 releases
neurotransmitters which are caught by
self 3 so 3 makes its own impulse the
impulse travels down cell 3 cell 3
releases neurotransmitters which are
caught by cell for cell four makes an
impulse the impulse travels down cell
for cell 4
releases neurotransmitters which are
caught by cell 5 the impulse is created
and it travels down cell 5 well where is
that impulse going we saw this before
here's a motor neuron sending an impulse
to some muscle cells how do the muscle
cells react when they are zapped with
that impulse the muscle cells begin to
stretch and contract and it's what
causes movement so we've tracked in this
video how neurons send signals from
neuron to neuron to neuron and
eventually how that signal causes your
muscles to move and react
and so there you go there's a hopefully
a good understanding of how neurons will
send impulses and how they communicate
with other neurons here in my class
pause the video try to answer these
questions and thanks for watching